la france occupe une première place en
europe qui n'est pas forcément très
valorisante nous sommes en effet les
premiers consommateurs d'antibiotiques
conséquence notre première place aussi
dans la résistance aux bactéries dans
ces traitements comme le dit la
publicité réalisée pour faire des
économies de la sécurité sociale si on
ne vous a pas préconisé d'antibiotiques
c'est que vous n'êtes pas vraiment
malade et issia book
la france championne d'europe enfin en
football mais en consommation
d'antibiotiques 80 millions de
prescriptions l'an dernier sur ce sujet
chaque patient à son avis d'expert qui
effectivement qui nous meut prescrit des
médicaments des antibiotiques lorsque
c'est nécessaire
ceci dit le cercle je ne suis pas
enclins à consommer d antibes de sites
web c'est vrai que je n'en ai jamais
parlé avec elle et puis ça me rassure
quelque part c'est bête à dire mais
quand on m'a prescrit les antibiotiques
c'est pas automatique
à coup de campagnes de sensibilisation
comme ce spot publicitaire donc de pas
mal à une chine alors tu es si gentil
que la consommation a chuté de 5,6 pour
cent entre 99 et 2002 un succès limité
résultat des bactéries deviennent de
plus en plus résistantes et selon li nvs
aujourd'hui un staphylocoque doré sur
trois résiste à sion d'antibiotiques
habituel il faut arrêter cette course
effrénée la consommation des médicaments
quels qu'ils soient en général et
particulièrement les antibiotiques il
faut que les médecins fassent de la
résistance dans le bon sens du terme
il résiste à cette demande permanente
d'antibiotiques et que l'on revienne bon
usage traditionnel des antibiotiques
premier responsable de cette
surconsommation les médecins de ville
qui prescrivent 90% des antibiotiques
des raisons liées aux patients avec les
patients qui demandent parce qu'ils sont
persuadés que prendre des antibiotiques
va permettre de les guérir mieux plus
vite et lutter contre un certain nombre
de symptômes sont des raisons liées au
médecin parce que ne pas prescrire c'est
une vraie compétence et c'est plus
difficile que prescrire solution
efficace pour diminuer cette
consommation identifier la maladie pour
mieux prescrire depuis 2002 partout en
france les médecins disposent d'un test
de diagnostic rapide des angines le but
définir si elles sont d'origine
virale ou bactérienne dans ce second cas
seulement le médecin prescrira des
antibiotiques